hey coordination is Charlie so Nick just
posted an official trailer for book
three spirits so I'm gonna do a full
breakdown of that I know a lot of you
have been sending me links about those
leaked episodes - I'm not gonna repost
them so please don't put any pirate
links in the comments but I will address
what happened to kind of explain why the
leak happened and what it was all about
I'm not gonna do a review of those just
because it wouldn't be fair given the
video quality was bad and they were
Chilean dubs with english subs
retranslated so a lot of the dialogue
was off it was a whole big thing but
I'll explain after I do my trailer
breakdown if you're finding me for the
first time I'm just gonna be doing
weekly Korra bonus videos on like
Fridays or Saturdays be sure to
subscribe to get them now that we got
the trailer we're probably gonna get
book 3 episode 1 pretty soon within a
couple months at least so here we go
this is just gonna be a breakdown
shot-for-shot as we go through the
trailer it's a bunch of clips basically
broken into different parts in the
trailer so it's like a couple scenes
just broken into a bunch of parts first
off we have the new title sequence which
totally looks beautiful then we go
straight to Korra at Ba Sing se
confirming that the earth Kingdom is
gonna be a big part of the story then we
see what looks like a city made of metal
or just a fortress made of metal which
makes some sense given that metal
bending has evolved a lot then we see
Cora training with one of the new main
characters we don't know what her name
is but she's dressed in earth Kingdom
clothing so she might be one of the new
few core members of team avatar some of
the new characters that the show is
bringing in nice shout out for all those
sky bison we saw during book 2
airbending is a much bigger part of book
3 - so it's only natural that we see a
giant herd of sky bison speaking of
which here's actually a much better shot
of some of the new Airbender disciples
which moves directly to Tenzin surveying
an airbender temple in the distance here
we see someone sitting in prison
implying that that long shot was
actually a Tenzin staring at an
airbender jail or a temple being used as
a jail for an airbender this shot is
just a follow up from that metalbending
city we saw earlier with the airships
everyone's wearing metal plating and
that tower also looks like it's made out
of metal so here's where things actually
get really interesting this is back in
Republic City and we can see Lin's
police force of metal benders it looks
like it's MOC oh they're trying to rest
there but why is he on top of that
bridge maybe he jumped off a one of
Asami's airships otherwise he would have
had to climb up there this next shot of
Bumi is actually a pretty big deal it's
of him stopping a ball of air
using airbending which yes does not make
a lot of sense but what I've heard is
that the harmonic convergence in book
two in the new spiritual balance between
realms makes all benders more powerful
in general and turns some non-benders
from bending families into benders like
Bumi for instance being the son of an
avatar you'd expect him to be a really
powerful bender but that was not the
case because during Aang's time the
world was out of spiritual alignment I
think it's just a good example of how
things from book 2 will have
consequences in books 3 and 4 I really
like the idea of them paying off big
things like that so moving along it
looks like there's another White Lotus
prison with the Water Tribe this person
actually looks like they have the same
abilities as combustion man she might be
related to him or just have randomly
developed the ability from birth she
definitely looks like she's gonna be one
of the villains you can't trust those
combustion people just stay away just
back away this is another one of those
villains being kept in a prison but we
can't see his face so there isn't a lot
of context but this is actually the
female waterbender that everyone has
been talking about this year we've seen
different types of benders in prison so
it looks like the main villains will be
a group of people of just you know
different benders being held separately
based on their abilities but now
everybody cheer because the waterbending
twins are totally back and it looks like
they're helping out tonraq and Zuko we
actually saw Zuko in that leaked trailer
from a couple of months ago I even did a
breakdown of it so it's not a huge
surprise that he's in this new trailer
this is actually one of the other new
recurring characters that's gonna work
with team avatar it looks like they'll
be meeting him whenever they travel to
Ba Sing se this is actually a follow-up
from that tattooed man doing those
pull-ups it looks like he's just chasing
down Mach oh and Bolin somewhere in the
earth Kingdom it looks like the place
where they are is directly on top of a
lava flow this is just a shot of Zuko
riding his dragon
we actually saw this during that old
league trailer but this is nice shiny HD
footage this person has a lot of similar
features to lin beifong's so it might be
one of her relatives were supposed to
meet a lot of beifong's family in book 3
so I'm really excited this is a much
better shot of that person that korra
was training as an airbender it looks
like she's part of Lin's police force in
Republic City I know everyone's gonna be
really happy to see kya in this new
season it looks like she's just being a
badass taking down this Airbender in the
distance I know a lot of you were asking
me if she was going to be part of book 3
and now it's confirmed and she's
definitely doing way more
he'll people this is just a shot of
Asami taking down someone in the earth
Kingdom
here's I do some much better context for
that Airbender jail I was talking about
earlier it also confirms that the White
Lotus is the one keeping all these
different villains in their prisons I
know all you course I meet shippers are
going nuts after you saw this it looks
like corn Asami are gonna be spending a
lot of quality time together this season
this is actually the first shot of Lin
in the trailer which was kind of
surprising because she's supposed to be
a big part of book three she's staring
at that metalbending fortress that might
be the Academy that Toph created or just
a regular old fortress so this is spirit
form Jinora it looks like she's using
the spirit world is a way to investigate
an underground cave this is opal the
earth Queen this is the first shot we've
seen of her but she's been rumored all
year she's supposed to be the daughter
of the earth King from Last Airbender
and it looks like she might not be super
best friends with Team avatar even if
she's not one of the main villains why
do bad things always happen to avatars
that go to Ba Sing se so this actually
looks like people training in a
metalbending Academy which I'm really
excited to see here's the follow-up to
that scene from maka and Bolin running
from that earthbender a lot of these
scenes from the trailer are just taken
from the same moments and just spread
out across this trailer so it's really
like four or five scenes just broken
into a bunch of pieces this is a much
better shot of that Airbender villain
that Kyle was yanking out of the air
with her waterbending this is actually
some confirmation that Zuko is working
with the White Lotus it probably has
something to do with tracking down all
these villains here's Korra doing some
badass metal bending I can't remember
the last time I saw her metal Bend and
this is actually a pretty big deal the
Dai lis are back and capturing Jinora
for some reason despite the fact that
the earth King disbanded them during the
last airbender here's another shot of
that new Airbender character again it
looks like he might be having some fun
with the team avatar when they first
meet like the time we first met Toph as
a child and she was not the friendliest
of people this is actually one of my
favorite shots from the trailer it's
just Korra using her airbending to sail
a desert ship away from the jaws of sand
sharks
here's beifong and training there isn't
a lot of context but there's got to be
something happening in the earth Kingdom
that's got to bring her back
I'm guessing that'll be part of the Dai
Li plot and the White Lotus film plot
will be something that's totally
different
here's ma ko fighting that evil
waterbender there's some scenes from
later in the trailer too
is actually the first real shot of a
spirit in the physical realm it's just a
giant spirit will remember at the end of
last season spirits started to come back
into the physical realm but this is the
first shot we've seen at one in the
trailer so here's just a bunch of fight
scenes cut together obviously the most
important one being that group of
villains that looks like they escaped
from all their White Lotus prisons in
this last shot is just a callback to all
the spirit vines that were growing in
Republic City last year and so that's
basically it just for reference about
50% of that trailer footage was part of
those leaked episodes so they did
release new footage which is really cool
they didn't just recycle stuff that had
already been leaked the picture it
generally paints is that there's a team
of villains made up of different types
of benders that the White Lotus and Zuko
will be dealing with that's probably
gonna be the main threat and then
there's the earth Kingdom plot with the
earth Queen and the Dai Li that's
probably going to be the B story the one
that will feature beifong Jinora and the
other side characters they did not add a
release date to the trailer which kind
of sucks but the first book - trailer
aired about two months before the book
to premiere so that means that Nik is
either going to air the first episode in
August or the other option is is that
they'll move it way up because of this
leak and start airing episodes in July
we'll just have to wait and see but
until then I'll be doing weekly bonus
videos on Fridays or Saturdays and then
once episodes start coming back I'll be
doing review videos with q and A's so
bet the leak here's a little bit of an
explanation about what happened and what
was going on so mundo Nick basically the
Mexican office for Nickelodeon
accidentally posted the episodes on
their website because of the way Nick
distinguishes between seasons and books
they just got confused and they were
posting book two episodes online they
mistakenly thought that book three was
part of that so they got posted they
were up for almost a full day before
they got taken down but they were
actually Chilean dubs not Spanish which
is kind of weird but whatever so just
looking at the trailer as well as some
of the you know leaked images that were
posted all over the place online the
animation looks amazing compared to book
to studio Mir is doing everything this
season it did looks like they rushed
things a little bit but there's still an
amazing animation studio so I'm really
excited it also seems like they really
plotted the season from a story and
character perspective much much stronger
than they did during book 2 I think
overall these new episodes will be some
of the best core that you guys have ever
seen but now it's your turn let me know
in the comments below what did you think
of the new trailer
and what are your theories about the new
villains the cool thing is is that
because they ordered book three and book
four at the same time and they started
plotting out those stories a lot of the
villains as well as the bigger stories
will carry over from book to book
so in related news my next core video is
going to be a Q&A so be sure to
subscribe to get it
I'll be posting that tomorrow you can
actually click on this annotation to get
it all added as soon as I post it and
then click here to learn about the new
Star Wars Episode 7 going thank you so
much for watching I'll see you guys
tomorrow
high fives